through
i would personally try to play for the
win and go around around a bit just to
hope that there's a way uh the opponent
blunders but okay he does have less time
than hanson now and he brings his rope
back to where it came from this is the
second time we've seen this position as
well if white brings his rook behind the
white queen that will lead to a draw
that will be the third time we will have
seen that position so naradisky moment
of truth for him is he going to keep
pressing was he going to admit that
hansen's just defended too well
ten seconds now and he brings his rook
back it's the third time we've seen it i
think
or maybe i'm wrong no no not yet not yet
not yet normally i'm great at
calculating that mode no three-fold
repetition yet if white brings this rook
back that will be a draw this time and
okay that's the moment of truth
there we go it is a draw
and hansen holds miraculously wow okay
daniel naraditsky we can see he's not
too happy about this as you guys
mentioned this was a game he wanted to
win
uh in the fight for qualification to
knock out stage a draw no crisis